welcome to this video bit of a late
start against fish puppy let's see um
Queens gambit no Queen pawn let's see
Bishop edge for there's a funny movie a
queen d6 the ideas queen before and
after that move I have honey move Queen
h6 I know this looks very strange but it
is quite good the point is that I have G
hive now and yeah he must he must play
he must play Bishop g3 and yeah
let-let's we would see that he has no
way to avoid material losses now 94 I
take only for and it's a double threat
against the bishop and the night and I'm
winning a piece then it's quite funny he
must play Bishop g three days no other
movie 3 is a mistake he must play Quincy
one if i'm not mistaken
Bishop g3 takes f takes this is
important g-form and this wins the e3
pawn
yeah there's really no move
yeah you can try to make a piece psycho
out of it but I don't really think I
don't really see a way to make it work
94 de for Bishop g5 Quincy 6 cm and it's
again a piece maybe it's trying to get
this to work nope I know it's really
funny if you've never seen that it's
white it can it can completely read at
you but it's it's really a good line I
mean Quincy one is just leading to
approximate equality check okay now the
problem is this is not not just the loss
of a pond it's also the Queen only three
were just completely paralyzing White's
position how do you get your pieces out
it's not not so clear good night on e to
the bishop on everyone is pinned um okay
just just going for long castles
yeah queen bee three is not playable
that's Queen d2 b should be three
checkmate so yeah yeah but I can take
probably this one let's think for a
moment do I have a better museum oh come
on if I've is strong it just opens up
the center if it takes the bishop takes
and the bishop only three years almost
as as problematic as the Queen now I'm
threatening to take on d4 to open up the
center now let's see disaster you cannot
take you 5 SC 5 hangs so now just rupee
adium tending to take
yeah I guess night takes with 93 should
be should be quite good mmm just not see
former probably attacking be too he
cannot really defend the pawn or to d3
both both looking good that's not bad
for a deaf to be too it's a bit much
okay we can also take here I am or f2
come on it's a rocker chuck rock is the
rook and take default first right
reasons yeah just an opening disaster
but it can it can happen so easily here
the good thing about this this idea with
Queen D sixes it's a it's not risking
anything and sometimes you get this kind
of kind of funny quick wins um this is
still okay go in here and now we must
play Quincy one and this is this is fine
no problem for white here it's
questionable what black should do i
cannot i cannot play g5 now i mean i can
but it's it's not not so convincing this
you know Bishop takes can do that but
it's not clear that it's and now g5
thanks night moves somewhere and then i
take the form i can do that it's that
sets a bit crazy i can just take and get
you to this kind of position
we're just about equal India III SS
losing really and did such a harmless
looking move because of g5 and no no way
to save to save right now like just wins
apiece here order the dreadful position
in the angel game where he is completely
paralyzed porn down and the Queen
dominates the position yeah this is a
useful useful idea to remember against
this type of Bishop g5 if you play the
Queens gambit or d45 structure then this
might be might be useful to know it's
not it's not like and leading to an
advantage but you can sometimes score
easy points with it and you don't risk
much okay thanks for watching